[Music]
welcome everyone thanks for coming to
our session where we're going to talk
about the future of meetings my name is
Sarah Chappell I'm a product manager
working on enterprise collaboration and
this is my colleague Patrick wind also a
product manager on hangouts and
specifically for video meetings and so
today I want to reinforce some of the
message you heard this morning at the
keynote we're all in on enterprise
communication and whether it is textual
team communication over chat team
communication over video and extending
into interactions such as with the white
board rather jam board and so today this
session will go do a deep dive on the
hangouts meet experience that we
presented this morning and I'm going to
talk about an epidemic throughout this
talk and it's a silent epidemic in the
workplace more specifically I'm talking
about the fact that 16.7% of every
workday is getting wasted my day is full
of 30-minute meetings and many of them
are online meetings and imagine losing
five minutes to setup for every one of
those meetings that's sixteen point
seven percent of your allocated time and
of course I use this number figuratively
but still an incredible number even if
it was five percent
imagine being able to give your
workforce and all of your teams five
percent of their time back here's how we
waste time
we waste time figuring how to get things
to work you have to download software
for many of many online meeting
experiences you might not have the
administrative privileges to install
software your IT department might be
whitelisting software so you have to go
file a ticket get permission to install
piece of software X to get to get into a
meeting of course the usual struggles
with the audio and video issues of
trying to understand which microphone
you're using the cameras you're using
and then one that we often forget is
that oh I'm using system X so I'll need
a system X account and then I'll have to
go create an account I have to remember
the password I have to log in all of
these things cost us time and make us
less efficient I work with global teams
I'm based out of Stockholm in Sweden
Patricks based in in the Bay Area
many of my colleagues here in front with
me work out of the our Kirkland right
outside of Seattle office and we work
very closely together so we need tools
that can support our reality of global
engineering we're all on the move we all
try to balance life family life and work
being able to take meetings from outside
of the office where around the goal is
an important part of our of our workflow
and more and more the company intranet
doesn't mean anything anymore
we source out from engineering we source
out some testing some marketing you work
with legal people from other companies
and so this domain focus on
communication tools needs to be broken
up because it doesn't match the the
workflows that we have today so I did
some napkin math in my talk yesterday I
shared a little bit about the meeting
numbers at Google internally we've got
somewhere close to 70,000 employees
these employees dial into video meetings
230,000 times everyday they dial in
across their laptops their phones or the
meeting rooms and we spend about nine
years actually at nine point two nine
point three years of time every day in a
video meeting so if we were to incur a
loss of a loss of five minutes for every
one of those meetings due to trying to
set up or trying to get things going
that's over two hundred thousand dollars
in lost productivity every day I'd like
to find a CIO that would be willing to
sign a purchase order for two hundred
thousand dollars every day because of
lost productivity so this is a fun
number but really what it's all about is
about removing the interruptions that
can create frustration these break the
flow they hurt our ability to do good
team work and you know they harm these
moments of connection that you create
with your teams from that are spread all
over the world and while we can look at
Google's use case you've all been
incredible at giving us feedback on the
solutions that we had in the enterprise
and what's staggering is that Patrick
and I we've talked to many of you that
use video meetings more than what Google
does and you use video meetings in ways
are very different to what Google does
and we've learned a lot from these if we
were to if we were to categorize the
feedback we'd put them in under several
pillars and I'll walk through these
pillars now things are too hard to
access hard to get into a meeting hard
to invite people especially customers
people that are external to your domain
I often use the example I want General
Motors to be able to talk to Ford as a
hypothetical example and this should
work
you can't expect Ford employees to have
general motor addresses or vice versa
and when things fail you want to back up
maybe you're on the road maybe you're
driving the ability to dial into a
meeting was also a key piece of feedback
that we've received and access is also
about not missing out if you can't be
there if you're not available and
recording was a key piece of feedback in
this these systems are hard to use
there's a lot of buttons there's a lot
of knobs it breaks confidence simple
actions just as presenting feel
converter contrive them and and again
you lose this this feeling of confidence
when you're talking to your audience
another piece of feedback we've gotten
is that a lot of the system's out there
the user experience is different whether
in the conference room on your laptop or
on your phone and so trying to add
consistency across all the devices one
supports is important we've heard a lot
about performance issues audio issues
video issues user experiences that
aren't snappy aren't responsive enough
bandwidth requirements that are too high
deployments that don't work across
corporate networks that are firewall
that have enterprise that has enterprise
requirements and so of course we took a
deep look at our own usage but the the
the fantastic thing was all this
feedback that we've been able to receive
from you and build into a great product
and so that's why today we're
introducing hangouts meet we feel that
this is video conferencing a video
conferencing experience that will give
you sixteen point seven percent of your
day back and it just works
so we're going to do a demo and Patricks
going to help out a little bit similar
to what the demo that was done this
morning but we're going to go much more
in-depth into it so let's switch to the
laptop please and so this is Google
Calendar and the cloudy coffee company
has been invited to a meeting and just
as normal with a calendar invite you can
open it and follow the link to the
meeting so from Google Calendar from an
email from your favorite messaging app
that link can be opened this is a Chrome
browser no plug-in no software was
downloaded to get to this experience and
everything I'm gonna demo today no
download no software native to the
browser this is a green room this is
where we can check our hair this is
where we can mute ourselves it's to make
sure as well that I don't join a meeting
by accident that I join when I'm ready
but more importantly if I'm in a Google
powered conference room I might want to
not join the full meeting maybe I'm in
this room just to present to the meeting
because I have the video conference
already running in front of me and you
know I took this out of my little travel
bag today these are all the adapters I
travel with HDMI to USB C DVI to display
port VGA of course cuz you know you
can't go anywhere without 1980s
technology and this is VGA to USB see I
mean there I mean this looks like I
don't know about you but it feels wrong
so if so if I want to just present I
present I choose what I want to present
and it shows up on the TV and to my
audience on online but now we're going
to go in the meeting full in and before
we do that this is an i5 Chromebook from
early last year and we're running we're
just running Chrome
and I want to just take attention to how
quickly I get into the meeting from here
boom so this is about 80 90 % faster
than the old or the classic hangout
thank you
and if we're allowed to geek out a
little bit like we've rebuilt the whole
JavaScript it uses half the RAM of the
classic hangouts experience this
experience when there's much much more
video frames per second than the
previous experience and it also reaches
HD quality much faster whereas the
classic hangouts could take up to 10
seconds to reach HD quality to ramp up
to not overload the network this one can
do it under well-well-well under a
second in fact the average we're seeing
average times of 100 200 milliseconds to
reach HD quality so online with me we
have our product managers in in Kirkland
hi Erica hey and we have boy Jana who's
sitting in a chromebox for meetings our
Drita room in our data loss is 5 and hi
to both and so I'll walk you through the
UI of this experience so we've we've
worked hard at making things simple
getting things out of the way of your
conversation the first one of the first
things we've learned is that documents
when we do document sharing they're
often taller than they are wide so we've
moved the thumbnails to the side we've
also made the commands to control the
meeting very simple so by just moving
your mouse you see I can mute myself I
can hang up I can mute the camera and
most importantly I can easily present
and we've worked with a chrome team to
redo the whole presentation UI flow so
that now you feel you'll have an
experience that puts you much more in
control of what you're selecting to
present whether it's a chrome tab a
window or your whole desktop thanks
Patrick and finally this is a meeting I
might want to invite other people
that were not on the calendar to this
meeting so I can easily pull up the
meeting information copy this to my
clipboard and share it out and I think
this is what we're going to do now so
we're going to pretend that we're
virtually sending that yellow and now we
have someone knocking in Katie works at
the cloudy coffee company she's outside
of hooli she doesn't have a gmail
address she has never heard of the
Google she's never heard of Google but
she can still come in without any
account so let's admit Katie into our
meeting and Katie somewhere here sitting
ah can you say hi
so she just joined on the iOS client for
for hangouts meet and this was also a
problem individuals that are sometimes
doing freelancing or going to an
interview they don't want to share their
private Gmail address and I remember
talking with Chris about this a while
back we've seen people with Gmail
addresses such as I hate BBC l78 at
gmail.com and you don't want to show
that to an employer you don't want to
show that in a meeting context and you
don't want to force people to go create
just a new gmail addresses just so they
won't show up in a meeting so being able
to be completely a countless and and
going into a meeting is then is a core
part of this experience let's talk more
about mobile shall we short you take
that part while I drink a little water
okay yeah so we have a mobile client for
Android and iOS and they're
purpose-built for this enterprise
experience with Serge mentioned so if we
switch the wolfvision
so this is just a standard Google pixel
and what you'll see here is that we have
an app that's designed for this
experience like you said earlier it has
has that contacts built-in I don't even
notice we pulled the information from
calendar so if someone has bothered to
put all that pep information into
in the calendar we surface that within
the meeting and it's no exception here
so I can click on this meeting here and
you can see all the meeting details you
can see who's invited and so on so it's
all integrated that way and I can also
join the meeting so if I click back on
join there and it was also linked there
earlier so you're going to mute here for
a second so we don't get any feedback
but this is what the experience is like
for someone so this is where KDC is
basically right now and how iOS device
and again you see all the same details
it's just there to keep you in context
where you can catch meetings on the fly
you don't have to read your crib notes
and then switch back to the meeting so
that's all fun I'm going to quit the
meeting for now the other thing we
realized was that the reality is that
you're running on the go to airports I'm
sure some of you took a loo through
airports or landed and took off from
them at least when to get here and when
you're in on the go especially when
you're roaming or something like that
the reality I know it's 2017 but you
just don't have access to to the
internet on your phone so you still need
to get into your meetings and we
understand that so with every meeting we
have on the enterprise sorry if you get
Enterprise G suite every meeting will
give you a dial in number and pin and
that's unique to that meeting so you
don't have to worry about deploying
numbers or host pins and all that stuff
it just works like you just create your
meeting and you get it so if I join this
call here just is just an ordinary phone
call you can see one click to to connect
one to send the meeting code and I'm
going to mute again and that just
connects me through so I don't have to
type in the pin and it'll just help me
join the meeting a lot quicker so you'll
see once that's entered then I will join
the meeting and you're on the way now
the other thing to show is that so I'm
going to quit that for a second here
[Music]
we've integrated that directly into
Google Calendar as well so if I jump
back into the calendar here you can see
here's the original calendar event you
saw earlier all those details are also
in in the calendar event invites so if I
click the phone number there again you
get the same click to join experience so
generally it's about two clicks and
you're into the cold doesn't matter
whether you're on iOS or Android and
that's that thank you
and that's an important thing to
remember every meeting you create with
this system if you're an enterprise G
suite user you will get a phone number
and PIN attached to it automatically
it's fire-and-forget it's a default part
of the experience I learned to not wrong
I roamed too much internationally last
week and I lost data access because I
had to confirm to my carrier that yes I
had spent up on my my data and then so I
wasn't able to join a meeting book click
switch to the mobile phone so Thank You
Patrick we switch back to the slide
let's switch back to the slides thank
you
we've been testing this in September at
over 300 companies that are G suite
users we've had 15,000 and user accounts
creating hangouts meet user meetings
since then and the feedback has been
really positive so thank you to all of
us who are part of our Early Access
program with our UX research group we've
done a lot of interviews we've done a
lot of surveys and we can confidently
say that the this user group has felt
that audio and video quality that their
satisfaction with audio and video
quality is more than doubled and that
was I think that was an amazing moment
for us to get those results to get those
results in
so we're at we're talking about an
enterprise context we're talking about a
shift of a video conferencing experience
into the enterprise and it's very
important for us to show not only that
we're we're not stopping here we've got
a team of people working on amazing
features coming up over the next few
months I can see some of my engineering
colleagues here a bit nervous gonna
spill the beans but I will spilled some
beans and so here's what we're working
on and here's what we expect to have to
be able to either have in your hands as
testers or as a full as a full blown
feature before the summer summer in
Sweden comes a little bit later just for
you both internally at Google we've
turned on we've turned this on a few
weeks ago
you can save meetings to Google Drive
and you can share them as a video file
afterwards and we feel this is going to
be super impactful and we'll be
releasing this over the next couple of
months and we're really excited about
this feature for certain enterprise
customers this is not possible this
should not be allowed so of course you
will have the you will have the levers
inside of your administrator panel to
turn this on or off at your at your
desire hangouts meet today's support 30
fully participant participative
participants shouldn't have written that
that was a tongue twister and this is
important this isn't a system where I
pass a speaker baton and say it's your
turn to talk now it's your turn to talk
this is a system that works for teams
where everyone can talk where everyone
can interact and so that building a
system like that means a much higher
load on on the infrastructure and on the
clients but we're happy to announce that
again before the summer
we'll be supporting larger meeting rooms
of up to 50 fully participative
participants thank you everything that
you've seen doesn't require any server
any infrastructure locally it's all
cloud powered but your career as an
enterprise you are also conscious of
bandwidth costs and so are we and so
we've been working hard at upgrading our
cloud infrastructure to reduce the
requirements on bandwidth for powering
these meetings and so there's no
on-premise software now on premise
Hardware everything's powered by our
cloud and the requirements for driving
beautiful meetings from hangouts me are
going to go down over the next few
months as well as we've improved a lot
of our infrastructure we've also worked
closely with a chrome team as an
administrator you can now push a chrome
policy that tells the browser to use
this range of UDP ports because your
corporate firewall and your your
internal security responsible might have
these policies already in place so as an
administrator you can tell all of your
browsers to go to this set of ports and
that means that connections will
probably happen a lot more direct and in
the past if ports were blocked or the
right port range wasn't used hangouts
meat might try to default and be and
tunnel itself over web traffic and we
all know web traffic is very different
to real-time traffic requirements of
audio and video so this is to help help
improve your connection rates and also
help improve the performance and the
quality that you see we've also we're
also going to be releasing as part of
chrome support for authenticated web
proxies and yes this also feels like VGA
but there are many many many companies
today where all the browsers
all the all the internet access is done
through web proxy still today and so the
having support for that means that
you'll be able to talk to your banker
I've worked at Google for 10 years I
have never received feedback like this
for a product and these are customers on
our EAP I have grayed out the names and
email addresses that went through the
bug filing tool to give us to tell us
that they love the experience that has
never happened so that for me that was
that was a moment when we sat together
with the team said yes we should may go
for it and launch it so thank you to all
that have submitted this feedback it's a
it's been an amazing source of
motivation for us thank you
so we're going to continue to work
really really hard at polishing
polishing polishing removing friction
everywhere we see it and our model is
really to give you 16.7% of your online
meeting work day back so that you have
time for these kinds of hangouts instead
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]